following that story and now bringing
you more breaking news we are getting
this is via the Reuters news agency
we are just hearing that Prince Harry
his wife Megan and her mother have been
involved in a near catastrophic car
chase involving paparazzi that's coming
from a spokesperson for Prince Harry and
we're told that the incident lasted over
two hours and resulted in multiple near
collisions as I said this is coming from
Prince Harry's spokesperson so just to
recap Prince Harry his wife Megan and
her mother Doria have been involved in a
near catastrophic car chase involving
Paparazzi photographers this is coming
from a spokesperson for Prince Harry we
do know that Megan and Harry were in New
York last night for an award ceremony at
which Megan was receiving and or board
we saw Prince Harry Megan and Megan's
mother on the red carpet and it seems
that leaving that event or sometime
after it there was
um
a Chase it's being called by Prince
Harry's uh spokesperson to chase
involving Paparazzi photographers in
cars Megan was at the women of vision
award in New York last night and so
that's all we're hearing at the moment
it was the couple's first public
appearance since the king's coronation
in New York
um one of the the first public sightings
of the Duchess of Sussex since that
coronation as well a big public display
on the red carpet as Megan arrived to
collect that award their mother Doria
Megan's mother rather Dory at Ragland
with them
um a couple of course based in
California but out there in New York
um for that award ceremony last night so
just to recap what we're hearing from
Prince Harry spokesperson is Prince
Harry his wife and his mother-in-law
involved in a near catastrophic car
chase involving Paparazzi photographers
that is from Prince Harry spokesperson